appalled you first was this enough today
it was enough for me it felt like was a
telethon that wasn't clear when they
were a video about a product so so now I
mean here's the thing that puzzles me
about it all is you know what was
different what was the Delta between the
last announcement and as you call it the
rya nouncement today other than that
they're now closer to a ship date you
know it wasn't like the old iphone you
know if you recall they did the
announcement i think it was in january
and then five months later they kind of
renounced in the sense of launching but
an awful lot changed between those two
days as near as i can tell very little
change between the initial announcement
of the watch and today we sort of begs
the question of you know why so long
other than just getting manufacturing to
scale up and maybe stabilizing some
software it actually made the
announcement feel fairly man yeah
interesting Brad my theory is that they
actually wanted to seed the market full
of competitors so they could see what
other ideas were out there Brad what do
you think if that way well that was it
they did a pretty good job because there
certainly have been many Android the
where devices that we've seen in the
last six month that really have not done
well and have not proven themselves to
customers but I you know I agree with
Paul I think overall it was a good day
that new macbook is getting great
reviews the fact that they've got the
exclusivity on HBO now the decrease in
price for the Apple TV you know for the
Apple watch while I've been a little
skeptical I think this is the beginning
of a big mountain that Apple is going to
climb and that's you know bringing
wearable computers into our lives and in
particular proving out the health
function the fitness function of these
devices now this is version one I think
we're going to see future versions that
are packed with much more health sensors
as they become more affordable and can
be supported by bet by a battery that
lasts for more than a day so if you can
hold off it's probably best to follow
that conventional wisdom that you
probably don't want to buy the first
version of anything and I think applies
here to the Apple watch today Paul do
you think businesses will be built on
this new device
oh I'm sure they well whether they're
successful or not I have no idea but
I've seen it I've seen it already i mean
there's a host of companies that are you
focused on you know the watch and you
know related smartphone platforms as
their you know their core market and
they're going to build it for it um I've
seen nothing yet that shows me anything
that she couldn't have been done
somewhere else and would probably have a
bigger place to build for but currently
business is building for it but it's not
obvious to me that they're going to be
you know real viable businesses they can
just target the watch